We knew that the web was the wrong
architecture for economic activity long
before Mythos.
That is why we built GRIDS, Gajumaru
remote instruction dispatch and
serialization.
A dead drop signature protocol that
removes the attack surface entirely.
The credentials are never on the
connected system. There is nothing to
find because the sensitive data was
never placed there.
I am going to show you this at work
right now.
Here we have Gajudesk.
A built-from-scratch zero-dependency
interface for the internet of economics
installed on my desktop. You can see my
wallet,
my Gaju balance,
my account ID,
and the GRIDS URL field at the bottom.
That is how we authenticate and sign. No
username, no password, no websocket. It
operates from the device's secure
enclave.
That means the private keys never leave
the signing context and never touch the
connected layer.
This is the highest level of
software-based security currently
available. Stage two of GRIDS will take
this further still, an air-gapped
dedicated hardware wallet with no
network connection of any kind. But this
is where we start, and it is already a
categorically better security posture
than anything else
in connected financial interfaces today.
This is a site we have built with GRIDS
integrated into the login and
operational flows.
I'm going to log in now.
I copy the GRIDS URL from the site
and paste it here.
Hitting okay,
I am then asked to confirm the messenger
signature request or the message
signature request.
I hit okay
and you'll see I am now logged in.
Almost instantaneously, I am logged in
to the secure client portal and
dashboard.
No password, no credential transmitted.
Now I am going to show you a
transaction.
I generate a payout to be signed.
This could be any transaction type.
I again copy the Grid's URL. I paste it
into the Grid's URL box
and I now get a transaction signature
request.
The account, the chain, the network ID,
the originating URL, and the transaction
data. I hit okay.
That's already done.
The transaction settled in under 3
seconds. You can see the transaction
hash. This is the proof-of-work open
resource blockchain Groot that is the
base of the Gajaru Maru making the
internet of economics possible.
1,846,200
times more transactionally efficient
than Bitcoin with 8.23 times greater
network security in commercial use.
Both the login and the transaction were
conducted using Grid's. There was no
direct credential interaction on the
connected layer.
Only the origination of the instruction
to the dead drop protocol as you saw.
One more.
This is Gajaru Market, the world's first
on-chain marketplace for goods and
services.
Currently in testnet.
You will note that here we see QR code.
This is how Guard You Mobile will
operate. You scan the QR code
and by the same mechanic log in.
For now, I'm going to use the GRID's
URL.
Again,
log in here,
confirm here,
hit continue here,
and I am logged in.
Same mechanism, no password,
no database to breach.
Guard You Desk is in use now. Guard You
Mobile will deploy in May.
These applications are free to download,
install, and use. The solution they
offer can be implemented by any business
or government in the world within weeks,
well within the 90-day cybersecurity
industry estimates for action.
The protocol is open sourced. The attack
surface that Mythos and any AI of its
capabilities can exploit is now gone if
you choose to make it so.
What you have just seen is GRID's at
work. This is not future technology. It
is operational now.
Mainnet launches 26th April 2026.
Thank you for your time.